so i'm peter
and i'm going to talk to you about
recompiling javascript
without restarting it um i'm a dutch
javascript developer
i you might have heard me from js1k i
organized that
and i build a variety of tools
javascript related tools
i work for a company called surfly they
do remote desktop in the browser
but that's not what i'm going to talk
about today so
first we start with a demo um
and so we're going to start with
reloading oh dear lord no
so we're going to start with re-enabling
engines
it's really exciting i know it's like
and there we go i hope there we go all
right so
um on the right hand side you see a
small animation basically right
the point is that it turns and it moves
and whenever i edit anything even
like adding a space it's going to
restart this
code there's a loop down here
sorry it's not indented i seem to forgot
that but if i change it
it will it will reload the code and it
will restart from scratch
so now let's look at how that will look
if you would recompile it
apparently that crashes
wow all right so that's cool um
okay sure no problem
so let's open the console turn it bigger
and bigger and all right so it's going
to repeat
repeating and whenever it's going to
start it's going to do foo
i'm sorry i had a visual thing and it's
apparently not working
so whenever i want to change it now
it's not going to print foo and if it
would it would print food and the
program would have restarted
as you can see in the console it's well
printing out the new stuff i can do
pretty much anything even like closures
um but that's let's just uh
try something quickly
such a pity oh well okay so no fancy
demo there
let's continue with the slide basically
what it is is it's compiling javascript
on the fly
um while maintaining access to closures
which is
something that's not that trivial to do
um obviously no restart of the
application is required
so if you're like building a game then
you wouldn't have to go through your
start menus and whatever
to see your change up and running
immediately it's
the library at least is a lazy
evaluation so it's compiling once and
it's only going to recompile when you
change it
and it's a generic approach meaning that
it will work with pretty much any
javascript
there are obviously some limitations but
i'll cover those later
so when i talk about compiling in
javascript what do i mean
when you have a function you're actually
compiling javascript because you're
preparing code to be ran so when you're
creating a function to be
invoked later you're actually compiling
javascript so that's what i mean when i
say compiling in javascript
all right so i'm going to do this live
coding thing and it's going to be
awesome
i'm sure just like the previous demo was
so
this one this one so we have a simple
set interval and it's printing hello
jsconf
um add a forgotten 500 millisecond
and so that's what it does
now the first step because i'm going to
recompile those functions is
i'm going to wrap those functions
so i'm going to create a new function
called well you know
and it's going to return that function
that i just sliced out
so this is the same as i had before you
know what
i should probably
so this is the original code that were
i press a button
i shouldn't be pressing buttons okay
so whatever um so this is the first step
and of course it still works still does
the same thing except
i sliced out the the way that the
function is being passed on
so the next step would be to actually
compile the function
and how do we compile functions in
javascript dynamically
eval now eval's evil so let's just
use the semantically more appropriate
way to do it
through function so we're going to do
like that and that should return the
same function that we had before
so let's try that still working all
right
okay so let's abstract this a bit
by putting it in a global variable so
that we can access it later
so this is still the same thing as
before just a bit of abstraction
and still works all right so
let's make this into a function id
parameter week's being passed on
zero because it's still the first
function in this array
still works now
are we able to recompile this point
because basically all we have to do
is change this right because this is
being re evaluated
and executed so let's just see if that
works
since we have a global we can access it
oh
capital
it doesn't work oh why doesn't it
doesn't why is it not working
this function get function is only being
invoked
once
it's not being repetitively being
invoked so when i change this
this isn't being picked up so what i
need to do
is i need to return a function
that does a recompilation so now we can
see that it's
recompiling but not executing so in
order to fix that
we can recompile we compile and we
immediately invoke all right that's what
these these are going to do
so now we can see that it's compiling
and printing all right
so now is it going to work if i try to
recompile
yes so this is recompilation as its most
basic primitive form
you're changing the runtime you know
without um
actually restoring the code now let's
see
we need to properly invoke this because
if we're going to do arguments
then this is not going to work in fact
what are other
things that might go wrong here i mean
if you're looking at re-compilation in
this approach
what kind of code if we're looking for
generic support what kind of code might
not work
anybody
all right good thing i've put a few up
um so function arguments are not going
to work because they're
simply being ignored right now closures
aren't going to work because you don't
have access to them
and that's probably like the prime thing
in this whole approach
function declarations don't return a
value
so if you would wrap those or replace
those then that would be
pretty much dead code named function
expressions are a special case
because the name of the named function
expression
is it's handled in a slightly different
way
and of course there's performance
because if you're going to repetitively
going to eval code it's going to hurt
your performance
so let's try to fix those cases um
first for arguments so argument is quite
simple
we're going to change this structure
into a set of objects
i should be typing object
all right so it's going to be args and
then
function accepts multiple parameters and
only the last one is supposed to be body
so
let's do args
and change this with body and this
should still work and still do the same
thing as before
note that we're just passing on one arcs
as a string um
but we we're going to fix that later
no it's still working hello jsconf so
um arguments let's say we take a new
demo
um i of course prepared a few of those
so let's try to use this
example and this is of course still a
simple example
um and it's going to repetitively print
out or call a log function which is an
alias
which has one argument text so if we're
going to replace that the same way as
we did before we need to slice out the
body
copy that into our data structure as
before
we're going to add a text parameter
then we have
we've got function 0 because it's the
first function that is going to exist in
this data array
and then the second object has no
arguments
i mean function
and so did i do everything oh no
all right so now we have basically two
get function calls
and they're going to return um
well the functions are generated through
whatever is in this array
so let's see if this works
it doesn't work and why doesn't it work
anybody see that
look at these two characters what's
missing here
the actual arguments so remember that
this function is a function as being
returned and being
invoked where the original function
would have been invoked all right so
if you look at the original code i've
replaced this function
basically with this function and so
that's being invoked
and in order to pass on the arguments as
originally attended
i need to change this piece of well this
snippet
to the standard uh apply
context and then uh array prototype
slice call arguments
0 or whatever way you want to do this
so in a nutshell this now is going to
invoke this
generated function as if it was invoked
originally
same context same argument as far as the
running code is concerned nothing
changes
and now it should work there we go okay
so now
we can still update this so we have
data 0 is this text or this body
and let's try to change that by say just
depending some kind of argument
and it's failing because oh no
wait
it's in quotes oh because i'm not
quoting it huh
no all right no i know why this isn't
working so i changed the
data structure and now so
i've changed the runtime from hello text
and just append a default without
restarting the application
so arguments are preserved and we can
mess with that all right so that's
one step so then if we have had
arguments
the next step would be closures all
right so we have
we fix for function arguments let's look
at closures
closures is going to be this snippet of
example
let's put it up here
so we are going to have a
function that's going to repeat whatever
is being passed on
so this function will be called below
and then set interval will repetitively
log out whatever
is being passed on so note that text in
here
is a closure over the text that's being
passed on
so if i'm just going to replace it as i
did before
actually i don't think i need to replace
the first one because it's still logged
text so that's remains the same except
for the
function i mean for the argument
because that's now in the second
function
which is the whole so this is like the
second function now and it's going to
wrap
this get function
all right so now let's see if this works
no because text isn't isn't defined and
the reason is not defined does anybody
can anybody figure it out like right now
why text would not be defined there
okay so yeah it's function
i heard somebody say it over there uh
function is actually a
indirect eval all right so it only has
access to the global scope
if we look at direct eval and indirect
evil the main difference
at least in this context is that direct
evil will have access to the
lexical scopes and because we're using
function over here
it's not working so let's change this to
eval
so we're going to change evil we need to
add the
function boilerplate now
arguments body
closing parts and the rest remains the
same
sorry yeah all right so let's see if
this works now
it still doesn't work what did we forget
so eval is lexical scope
so even though we're doing direct evil
right now
it's not going to be able to access text
because text
doesn't exist in this function it
doesn't exist in this function
and it doesn't exist in global scope so
that's why at this point it's still
throwing a failure so in order to solve
this
we're going to do something like this
and let me just give me a second
let's do it in order so we're going to
add a
compiler
let me just do this on a new line
okay the rest pretty much remains to be
the same thing
here and at least and then whenever we
do get function we pass on this compiler
as an argument and
this requires now a argument because i
mean this call
is this you know just passed on
so rather than evil we're going to use
this compiler to compose stuff
and in global scope we just pass on eval
because we don't care about
direct or indirect from global okay so
is it going to work now i certainly hope
so
hurry okay so at least it's working now
so let's see if we can actually change
the closure because this text over here
is a closure
remember that this function doesn't have
a closure a text argument
so let's just try to change it
not remove it change it and see if we
can
mess with it so
body equals dot
and it works so we're able to
we're able to recompile code now even
though there were closures in there
so it maintained access to those scopes
so we fixed closures
now the next part is function
declarations function declarations
require
a preprocessor step so if we have like a
function foo
then what we actually need to do is
rewrite this to varfu is function
their equivalent and the only other
thing you need to take into account is
that you need to move
this line to the top of the scope
because that's basically what javascript
does as well
so javascript will hoist those function
declarations and you can just use any
kind of parser
to rewrite this this part and make it
equivalent
in terms of javascript semantics so
that's the
for me at least that's a very simple
trivial way of getting rid of the
function declaration problem
use a parser for named function
expressions it's slightly
more complex so you'd have
sorry so you'd have like this case
actually it's not so interesting so the
right way of doing the
you know the paint loops with with
timers if you were going to use timers
anyways
um would not be set interval but set
time set timeout
and you do like a
and of course this would be like the uh
you know computed depending on whatever
okay it doesn't matter so this is how
you would do
your paint loop and then the problem
with this approach
in terms of recompiling is that you
don't get to change repeat anymore
so that value of repeat is is just being
executed or be just being assigned once
uh on top of that of course name names
of named function expressions
have more weird semantics but that's the
main the main point
um the main problem here so what we do
here is we're going to rewrite
the name function expression as well and
so rather than
this we're going to do a
actually we're going to wrap it in the
function so
so we're going to do this and then uh
this would be the actual code
and then we're going to return this
function
um so we're going to basically rewrite
rewrite this and that way we get rid of
the
named function expression while
maintaining the runtime semantics of a
name function expression
and this way we can actually use our
recombination stuff
so let's quickly try this just to prove
that it does work
sorry so we'd have this
and then we're going to wrap this body
again
there are no arguments to this function
and the name we don't need anymore
because that's going to be abstracted
away um in our rewrite
right i should have rewritten it first
huh
all right
so this is the rewritten part of the set
timeout and now i need to wrap it
i can still maintain the first part i
guess
and then use get function
zero this is still the first uh first
function up here
i think this is good and then we're
going to wrap the
uh the new function as well of course
and so it's going to be get function one
of course we need to pass on a compiler
and of course the compiler here as well
and i think no arguments i think this
will
work i hope anyways
uh let's
see if it works it doesn't work
does it need to be invoked immediately
no
all right well i guess you're just going
to have to assume or take my word for it
that works
i don't think i'm going to be able to
solve anything like right now anyways
the solution does work because the
semantics should be equivalent
all right so we've solved the name
function expressions
and then for um
yeah for performance we can actually
extend
of postpone it so let me revert
so that we had it what it was before i
think this was working
yeah okay so and we can change that to
this yeah
so what we do
is um instead of
compiling it every time in this step
basically
um we cache the function that's being
that's being uh
invoked and then we check uh whether
it's up to date so
we're going to add a closure or actually
two closures i guess
that's the function and that's the
version
we're going to do a version check
no not equal to our
local version and then we're going to
check whether function exists at all for
like the first time
and if it doesn't or if either of the
cases isn't true
whatever then we're going to compile it
cache that function let's see we need to
move this away sorry
update the version
i think this is fine
and then apply return func apply
now all we need to do is update the
sorry
yeah that's correct sorry
and i need to add the version to the
data object
which can be just like a
all right so now it's only going to
update the compilation and we can
sort of proof that i suppose by just
by checking it here and so this this
step should only be invoked now
so the actual calling of eval should
only be called now
when the code is changed
i'm not sure what it does twice right
now but uh whatever um
but as you can see it doesn't compile
now and so
uh what we can do now is we can change
the body of the code and it doesn't
recompile
because it doesn't see a new version so
as soon as we do that
and it can be anything i mean it can be
fu it doesn't really matter just doesn't
need to be the same as
before and then you can see it recompile
and then actually recompile
so it's a sort of lazy evaluation um
and still you know recompiling okay so
that was the last part of of the the
main issues
i had a slide for this also so direct
the first direct
evil the the trick the main trick to
this approach
is basically a indirect direct eval all
right
you're caching a function uh
oh that's what we're doing in this in
this uh why
am i not in this part right we are
creating a function on any scope of our
new functions
and that makes the dollar sign compiler
variable available
on any scope and that's why we can do
the get function compiler here
which basically just returns this
function and because this is a direct
eval at that point
it's going to have access to all the
variables and that's why closures are
working
there's actually one problem with this
snippet of code can anybody see
what what's what's going to happen at
runtime at some point
i doubt douglas crawford is going to use
this at all
all right so what happens if we do if we
recompile this
and we do
s that's what's going to do
it's going to see that variable because
it has access to closures
and because we're adding a new function
it's actually kind of adding a new scope
and if we declare variables in that
scope they're going to show up in this
recompiling step
so changing the version and we can now
see that it's actually
printing out the log so we're polluting
the scope of course we're also
polluting the scope with a compiler
function but that's a something that i
can't fix
for this one you can fix it by simply
removing this argument and saying
i mean you're already using eval right
so
might as well use arguments
all right so now it works and uh if we
change it
to that it's gonna cry because as is no
longer available of course we can still
print out
say compiler but that's again you know
use like greek letters or something i
don't know
uh ss oh wait this is not defined and i
was just gonna print that that
that compiler function but this is the
so this is the main trick uh
create a function that has a direct e
file and maintains access to the local
scopes
so basically recap it's
a approach that works
generically it works for pretty much any
kind of code
you can recompile you can change it on
the fly if you've seen
brett victor's talk uh inventing on
principle he does this like
you know at some point he does a this
loop and he changes it and he changes
the number of iterations to
uh i don't know whatever to change the
number of leaves in the tree and the
first time i saw it i was like
that's not possible you can't do that
and then later i have to disprove myself
of course
um because it is possible it's just you
know it takes magic
a bit of magic so
on every scope you inject a new function
a compiler function which has a
direct eval and by which you have direct
access to all the scopes
which maintains access to closures and
no that makes this work
and inside that you have some rewriting
magic for like function declarations
and other nasty things that might screw
this up
so some open issues
um the big the biggest problem here is
in certain new functions
because your mapping functions
one-on-one right and i've
i have the library where i um
do it you know i abstracted everything
away so you can just as you can so as
you can see in the
recompiler demo that doesn't really work
you can you know you can type here and
it will replace all the codes but it's
going to assume
that these functions are going to be a
certain order so if you add a new
function
you know inject it somehow it's going to
trip
up simply because it's going to run to
put this body or actually know this body
into
this body and so that's something that
i don't think it's very easy to solve
i've tried to you know i've tried to do
a diff
but dave won't help well only so far
because there might be changes
um that are spread on multiple parts in
the code
and in that case you don't know which
functions to replace so that's like
the biggest problem with this approach
but as long as you're not inserting any
new functions
everything is going to be fine the minor
issue is of course
the variable clashes that i explained
before
and it's actually very hard to explain
people don't seem to get
that you can't really um go ahead and
change the global code
right i mean if there's no way that if i
would um
at runtime at least if i would do this
versus bar
at runtime i will recompile this and to
say this like uh g
it won't be picked up because it's only
picked up by code that's re-evaluated
okay so this approach only works if
you're
if you have functions like well
callbacks that are going to be
reevaluated or
actually re invoked at some point um any
other code
which includes any global code it's it's
not going to work or at least it's not
going to be useful um it's going to work
but it's not going to do anything
so that seems to be hard to get across
unfortunately
so the code is going to be available on
github
as usual i will push it later
if github allows me to and otherwise
i'll you know
slides will be in there as well and uh
yeah
so are there any questions i have like
zero minutes left so that should be fine
okay
uh otherwise i'll be out there and
yeah thank you
you